TREES BECAUSE THEY'RE
RACIST.
LOCALS SAY THEY WERE PLANTED
MORE THAN 50 YEARS AGO TO
SEPARATE GOLF COURSE FROM
AFRICAN-AMERICAN
NEIGHBORHOOD.
LAST TIME WE SPOKE TO A
LOCAL RESIDENT ABOUT THEIR
SINISTER PRESENCE.
>> IF YOU HAVE DONE ANY
RESEARCH ON THE TREE, YOU
WILL KNOW ONE OF THE NSAEST
TREES AROUND AND KNOWN IT'S
BEEN DECLARED A DISASTER BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: WAIT, SLOW DOWN,
NOW, HOLD ON.
BECAUSE THAT TREE IS A
FOREIGN TREE, YOU'RE CALLING
IT NASTY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS
COULD PALM SPRINGS BE
OVERREACTING AT ALL TO THE
COURSE ARCHITECT.
A RADIO SHOW HOST JOIN US
TONIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL, ETHAN, YOU
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING.
THIS YOU ARE FROM
CALIFORNIA.
CLEARLY THIS IS THE
DEFINITION OF STRUCTURAL
RACISM.
THESE ARE TAMARIST TREES.
>> THE TREES THEMSELVES
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THESE TREES IN
PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN A FIRE
HAZARD THIS YEAR.
FOX HALLS DONE A GREAT JOB
COVERING LIKE THE THOMAS
FIRE.
THE TREES THEMSELVES HAVE
BEEN EXPLOSIVE DURING THESE
FIRES THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING.
SO NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE THE
ASPECT OF THE TRADITIONAL,
THE ORIGIN OF THE PLANTING
OF THESE TREES BEING TO
ACROSS THE STREET, AFTER
THEIR HOMES WERE DEMOLISHED
BY THE WAY BY THE CITY OF
PALM SPRINGS, UNDER RACIST
CONDITIONS, THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TIMES, LET'S SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT.
LET'S CLEAR THE TREES ARE
FIRE HAZARD.
WINS.
THE TREES ARE JUST NOT
BIGOTED BUT THEY ARE
FLAMMABLE.
FOREST, HERE IS MY CONCERN,
IF WE TAKE DOWN THE RACIST
TREES COULD THE HOMES BEHIND
THEM BE HIT BY RACIST GOLF
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT
NOTHING IS RACIST.
ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S WORLD.
>> Tucker: I WOULD DO BUT MY
EYES ARE OPEN NOW.
>> REALITY IS I DON'T KNOW
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE IS
ANY CLEAR INDICATION OF WHY
THEY WERE PLANTED.
ONE REASON THAT WE PLANT
CORRIDORS WHICH THIS HAPPENS
GENERALLY GET 350 TO ALMOST
400 IS TO PROTECT ADJACENT
HOMES AND PROPERTY, WHETHER
THINK THE WIN-WIN WOULD BE
TO GET EVERYBODY ON BOARD
AND SAY WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
>> Tucker: 2017 COMPROMISE
MODERN ERA.
AS A LAND ESCAPE GUY, ARE
THERE OTHER REASONS OTHER
THAN SIMPLY BIGOTRY THAT
THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PLANTED?
>> YOU KNOW, I DID AS MUCH
RESEARCH AS I COULD.
WHEN I WORKED BRIEFLY ON A
STUDY FOR THIS GOLF COURSE,
WE GOT A LOT OF HISTORICAL
DATA.
I WAS ABLE TO FIND WHAT WE
THINK IS AN EARLY 1960'S
IMAGE THAT ACTUALLY SHOWS
THAT THIS HEDGE OF TAMARIS
TREES WAS PROBABLY THERE
BEFORE MANY OF THE HOUSES
THE HEDGE WAS PROBABLY
PREDATED MANY OF THE HOMES
BEING BUILT THERE.
>> Tucker: OH.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY ARE NOT RACIST
TREES.
I MEAN, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT OBVIOUS
IF A TREE IS RACIST OR NOT.
ETHAN, LET ME GET AND I SORT
OF BUY YOUR POINT THAT THEY
ARE BOTH BIG GOUTED AND A
FIRE HAZARD.
I WONDER IF THIS ISN'T A
TEACHING MOMENT, RIGHT?
A TIME WHERE WE CAN ALL
LEARN.
INSTEAD OF CUTTING THEM DOWN
MAYBE WE COULD MAKE THEM
BETTER TREES SOMEHOW.
PRUNE THEM.
IS THAT NOT A POSSIBILITY?
>> NO.
LET'S JUST GET THEM OUT OF
THERE.
LET'S GET BACK TO SOME
NATIVE TREES THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
PURE DESERT.
>> Tucker: SLOW DOWN.
NATIVE.
FOR A GUY WHO IS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M SERIOUS.
PALM TREES ARE NOT NATIVE.
EUCALYPTUS ARE NOT NATIVE.
SHOULD YOU EXPEL EVERYTHING
FROM CALIFORNIA.
>> IT'S A BIG PROBLEM, TOO.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU A
NATIVIST NOW?
>> WHEN IT COMES TO
VEGETATION, ABSOLUTELY.
EUCALYPTUS TREES ARE A
>> Tucker: THEY WEREN'T
ORIGINALLY FROM CALIFORNIA
THEREFORE WE HAVE TO KILL
THEM.
>> COME ON, TUCKER.
WE HAVE A SEVERE WATER
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A LACK OF LEADERSHIP
IN SACRAMENTO.
IN D.C. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
WATER ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE DIVERTING WATER TO
WATER TREES.
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
CLEAR OUT.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT IF WE
CUT THESE DOWN YOU DON'T
TO PUT IN A PARKING LOT, DO
YOU THINK YOU MIGHT REGRET
THAT?
>> WELL, THE TREES ARE
SERVING A PURPOSE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THEY
COULD MAYBE BE REPLACED BY
BETTER TREES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> I THINK YOUR GUEST LAST
NIGHT MENTIONED EUCALYPTUS.
INTERESTING YOUR GUEST
TONIGHT IS SAYING NO
EUCALYPTUS.
>> Tucker: I HAVE GOT TO GO.
THEY ARE FOREIGN TREES.